[Music]
they're massive and extremely dense they
rip apart anything and everything that
gets close to them we can't see black
holes but we know they have the
destructive power to wipe everything out
of existence this is what F and here's
what would happen if a black hole
deleted the universe before we get to
the part where a black hole erases the
universe let's make something clear the
universe is a giant supercomputer
processing information without
information there can be no universe but
what is information in physics
information is the property of a
specific state of a particle I know it
sounds confusing here's a simpler way of
looking at it this is a carbon atom a
bunch of these can be arranged to make a
hard diamond but if you change the
arrangement of atoms you can get soft
graphite the basic building blocks are
the same it's information that makes
them different in quantum mechanics
information is like energy it can't
disappear into nothingness so how in the
universe can one black hole do the
impossible
that's the black hole information
paradox black holes act like monstrous
cosmic trash compactors they squeeze
stars planets and unfortunate astronauts
who cross the event horizon into a
microscopic point so what happens to the
information about every particle that a
black hole consumes since information
can never be destroyed it has to be
stored somewhere inside that black hole
right our original understanding of
black holes assume that everything that
disappeared in the black hole stayed in
the black hole the moment an object
passed the event horizon it got crushed
into the density of the black hole the
information about it could never be
retrieved again that's what we thought
before Stephen Hawking introduced
Hawking radiation
hawking realized that black holes aren't
static rather they release their mass
and energy back into the universe
particle by particle until there's
nothing left so does that mean the
information within a black hole can
somehow escape with the black hole's
outgoing radiation not quite the black
hole doesn't preserve the information it
consumes it chaotically mixes it
together with other bits of information
making it impossible to recover the
information is lost forever if the
information can be lost that would mean
that black holes can eventually delete
the universe forever but there is a
possibility that the black hole doesn't
delete the information it may be hiding
it in a baby universe a small
self-contained part of the universe that
branched off of ours
the information wouldn't technically be
lost but we wouldn't be able to interact
with it another possibility is that
black holes can encode the information
according to the holographic principle
if you were to get trapped inside a
black hole you'd still experience
three-dimensional space for us looking
at you from the outside you'd appear
stretched on the flat surface just like
a hologram that would mean that the
information paradox is resolved and we
don't need to rewrite the laws of
physics but we'd have to rethink our
understanding of reality the universe
could be a three-dimensional image
projected off a two-dimensional surface
and you may be a hologram on the surface
of a black hole and the best part the
black hole couldn't delete the universe
after all wait how could we be living in
a hologram
well that's a story for another what if
[Music]
hey thanks for watching and don't forget
to comment write in your what if ideas
down below